and the argument that they make is that
columbus came over to the americas and
he enslaved all the peoples and he raped
killed pillaged and burned and he was a
vicious tyrant and a murderer and he did
all of these awful things because he was
a genocidal maniac
and the problem with that narrative is
not just that it's unfair or it's out of
historical context
it's actually that it's not true in the
words of carol delaney who is a
preeminent columbus historian
the the
left accuses columbus
of things that he actually did not do
that other spaniards did that actually
in many cases christopher columbus tried
to stop the spaniards from doing
i'm dave rubin and we're doing a special
columbus day edition of the reuben
report today i'm joined by the most
notorious christopher columbus
apologist on all of the internet a man
who also wrote one best-selling book
with no words and another another
best-selling book with words that the
new york times decided not to put on
their best seller list also he left me
behind in crazy cali while he moved to
the free state of tennessee yeah you
know who it is michael knowles welcome
back to the reuben report
great to be with you sir albeit from
afar i i hope to see you in person again
soon if i can make it back to that uh
you know failed state of of nussolini's
california
yes thank you for sticking me right at
the beginning of this thing now knowles
i asked my guys because it is columbus
day i asked my guys who is the foremost
expert on christopher columbus and they
said uh they gave me a long list of
names we couldn't get any of those
people we got a single one yeah we
couldn't get them and then they said
michael knowles and i said well chris
columbus i thought perhaps you were the
expert on the director chris columbus of
home alone and harry potter and mrs
doubtfire have you ever heard that joke
before
yeah i i have not heard that joke it's
not a joke dave i would i would consider
myself an expert on both chris's both
very important although i suppose today
we celebrate the old italian one yeah
okay so let's let's talk about
christopher columbus because i actually
know the joking aside this this is sort
of close to your heart the way that
they've sort of changed
the very life and the history of
christopher columbus i've i've watched a
couple things that you've done on this
before so
actually i'm not even going to ask you a
question why don't you just start where
should we start when talking about
christopher columbus i think we ought to
quote that great historian tony soprano
i'll clean up the language a little bit
for your show because it's a family
program
when when his son aj is going off about
some howard's inn revisionist woke
nonsense about christopher columbus tony
cuts him off and says
hey enough of that in this house
christopher columbus is a hero all right
and that's the end of the story and i
think that's absolutely true there are
uh two reasons here why we focus on
columbus day and why this is near and
dear to my heart first of all
the identity politics i am an
italian-american from new york uh
columbus day is considered an
italian-american holiday it was
instituted for the first time
in 1892 this was on the 400th
anniversary of christopher columbus
sailing the ocean blue the the
approximate cause of this is that the
year prior 11 italian americans had been
lynched in new orleans it was it's the
largest mass lynching in american
history and so to make the italians feel
nice and welcome here in america there
was this initial columbus day celebrated
and then later on franklin roosevelt
made it an annual thing so the the
italians especially those from the
tri-state area feel very close to it now
beyond the you know the usual sort of
identity pride that everyone seems to be
focused on these days
why on his own merits would columbus get
a holiday well the answer is simple he
is the man who discovered america
without christopher columbus we would
not be here and he's a great embodiment
of western civilization he is an italian
a
genuine of low birth who is basically a
self-made man and he educated himself
and he traveled all over he became one
of the greatest sailors of his age even
when he was still a young man he had
this crazy idea to sail to the indies to
find a short sea route to the indies
the reasons for this were somewhat more
economic to find a trade route but they
and this is often overlooked they were
religious they were spiritual he wanted
to
he was a devout catholic he wanted to
fund another crusade actually and on his
ships he said the book of hours he led
the men in prayers he had confession in
the eucharist before he set sail he was
a deeply pious religious man and he was
intrepid he was fearless he sailed to
iceland to ireland to parts of africa
he makes it to the indies he goes three
times discovers a new world and because
he he so embodies our civilization
the left hates his guts
so let's
go with that for just a moment uh
so you're basically telling me he used
the tools of the white patriarchy to
come here and slaughter people right
isn't that going next with this
you know the italians are a swarthy
people getting back to our identity
politics so i don't know how where they
fall on white supremacy but i think yes
to to the left he was a an embodiment of
white supremacy and the argument that
they make is that columbus came over to
the americas and he enslaved all the
peoples and he raped killed pillaged and
burned and he was a vicious tyrant and a
murderer and he did all of these awful
things because he was a genocidal maniac
and the problem with that narrative
is
not just that it's unfair or it's out of
historical context
it's actually that it's not true in the
words of carol delaney who is a
preeminent columbus historian
the the
left accuses columbus of things that he
actually did not do that other spaniards
did that actually in many cases
christopher columbus tried to stop the
spaniards from doing when they first
landed they met the taino people
columbus
told the spaniards don't be cruel to
these people now there were other
islanders in the area notably the carob
islanders who were a little less kind
and polite than the taino indians
columbus noticed that the tainos had a
lot of scars on them on some of them and
so we asked where is that from it was
from the carob islanders the carob
islanders is where we get the word for
cannibal they were an island of
cannibals this is well documented and
you know this this brought the idea of
cannibalism even into our lexicon or
cultural lexicon so not all of the
natives created equal uh christopher
columbus befriended one of the uh indian
leaders and actually raised his orphaned
son
so to call him racist bigoted genocidal
it's just
it it is so overly simplistic it's so
dishonest and uh frankly it's more
fanciful and fabulous than any of the
the traditional narratives we have that
admire columbus so since we're taping
this actually a couple days before
columbus day
uh i'm sure that we're in agreement that
there's no doubt like 80 000 hit pieces
out right now they're doing hit pieces
post
you know post death hit pieces on
christopher columbus right now there's
no doubt they're saying you know
slaughtered indigenous er and all of
this stuff does this in some ways for
you because you care about this and and
at the identity politics level it's okay
to be an italian proud of italian
heritage and history and all of those
things that it's like we can't defend
any of our freedoms now we can't even
defend our current you know history from
ten years ago that this is one that it
almost feels like the ship has sailed no
pun intended like they're coming for
christopher columbus whether we like it
or not they are and these hit pieces
they crop up every year and they've
really increased in frequency and
vitriol since the mid-2000s and whenever
you look at a hit piece
what's the first question you gotta ask
the first question is
what are the sources where did they get
this stuff from it was a little weird
that these hit pieces all cropped up in
the 2000s and and the explanation was
that new documents revealed that
columbus was not a great guy that
actually he was a terrible genocidal
maniac
what were the documents it's actually
you'll notice on a lot of these articles
you can't find they don't cite their
sources
it all goes back to a document from a
man named francisco de bobadia francisco
de bobadia was christopher columbus's
rival for political power in the new
world columbus was not just the greatest
explorer of his age but he also was the
governor of the indies he was a less
competent governor than he was a an
explorer and actually a lot of the the
harsher uh treatment of the native
americans was as a result of of
christopher columbus being outfoxed
politically by much less scrupulous men
and so one of the people who stabbed
columbus in the back was this guy de
bobadia regardless of what i'm not i'm
not saying christopher columbus was
perfect obviously he wasn't he's a human
no human is perfect uh not not in this
day and age at least and i can really
only name one person you know one one
maybe two i don't know you dave you're a
nice guy but i don't think so so thank
you thank
you we look at at this historical record
i i think the comparison here would be
if you if you were looking at a history
of hillary clinton and you said okay
well what's a fair history of hillary
clinton uh how about this one written by
donald trump that's wha i'm going to use
this as my sole evidence that hillary or
vice versa you know the history of
donald trump written by hillary clinton
regardless of the the facts on the
ground and we can talk about all of the
complex facets of columbus's life it's
simply preposterous
to take his chief political rival as the
the gospel truth on the man especially
when when that narrative is so
contradicted by many other esteemed
historians and people who who were there
at the time i mean i think of bartolome
de las casas the first resident bishop
of the americas bartolome de las casas
was honest about columbus's faults and
he said you know the man didn't govern
perfectly but he was he's considered one
of the greatest defenders of the native
americans and yet de las casas remained
a lifelong admirer of christopher
columbus and i think we need to take
into account that historical perspective
as well before we throw the guy over the
ship as it were right all right so with
that in mind let's spend our remaining
time talking about the good stuff we
know the controversies are coming we
know what they're going to say okay so
be it and by the way none of these
people are leaving america none of these
people are doing anything other than
complaining and everything else but
let's let's be productive here and get
some real knowledge just on the
exploration part itself is there any
interesting stories that sort of got him
to decide yeah i'm gonna get in a boat
and see what happens like it's a pretty
crazy thing i mean the only the only
comparable thing we have in modern times
is that you know elon musk is you know
trying to send people to mars or that
kind of thing
yes
the thing you need to know about
christopher columbus's exploration is
that the man was unique this this is not
something to be looked at as the mere
tides of history and someone was going
to discover the americas and oh you know
if it wasn't chris it would have been
somebody else no christopher columbus
was so ruthlessly determined and
ambitious to find this sea route
that he first of all educated himself he
educated himself became literate became
a spaniard he was an italian guy but he
became a spaniard because he thought
that was going to be basically his best
chance to to go on over he lobbied the
king of portugal the king of portugal
refused he then goes and lobbies the
king and queen of of spain they refuse
as well but through basically sheer
tyranny of will and personality he
finally gets isabella queen isabella to
relent and fund this voyage he had
already had a lot of experience at sea
before that and then he sets to sea
what does he have all these wonderful
tools at his disposal no he's got a
compass and the stars he used dead
reckoning to make it across so you'll
often hear people today say christopher
columbus he didn't even end up where he
wanted to end up he wanted to end up in
the east indies he found
bermuda you know or whatever not bermuda
he found the bahamas he found the
caribbean and you think well i don't
know the guy had a compass and he had
the stars how far would you make it
probably not very far he also had to put
the can't get to the 405 without my gps
so i got of course not none of us can
you know uh on on this voyage
as they were going a far a far greater
distance i think that many people were
prepared to undertake uh christopher
columbus had to put down a mutiny so
here you do see a little bit of his
leadership skill maybe he wasn't the
greatest governor of the indies but he
did keep these men in line and they
finally do spot land and he
i think owes a lot of it to his faith in
god i mean when he when he finally does
land in the caribbean the first island
he lands at he calls it san salvador
right the or the savior and uh he he
deals with all of these difficult
political problems
he is brought back to spain in chains so
he undergoes a lot of persecution
and columbus doesn't just complain about
this by the way he he thinks he was
unjustly persecuted i think he was
largely unjustly persecuted there are
some cynical motives for it which is
that
as long as christopher columbus was a
criminal then the crown didn't need to
pay him what they owed him so there were
a lot of political machinations going on
in spain but he he understood that
perhaps he was suffering because of his
own failings so he and he writes about
this in his journals so he actually does
look in on himself and the the
two-dimensional picture is just so silly
not to harp too much on the criticisms
of him but i think there is an important
one that we need to focus on here which
is ourselves you know in the spirit of
columbus looking in on his own failings
we need to look in on ourselves without
christopher columbus we would not be
here without christopher columbus the
hispanic people would not exist there
would be no such thing as latinos or
hispanics right which is latino people
come from the mixture of the american
indigenous peoples and the spaniards who
come over so
if you're a hispanic person you owe your
very ethnic identity to christopher
columbus and we of course owe our
existence here in the new world and so i
think before we cast stones we should
recognize that we are standing on the
shoulders of giants this giant in
particular and yet we think that we're
flying yeah what else don't we know
about those those first days when he
reaches the new world is there anything
like particularly interesting from just
like it's just like hard to imagine well
how long did it take by the way so
i forget the exact number of days i used
to know this this pretty well uh but i i
forget the exact timing there are some
interesting stories though when he lands
on the first time and i think this is
also really important when we're talking
about the the native americans you know
the indigenous peoples from the region
because i don't mean to downplay the
suffering that they endured many of them
did endure a lot of suffering but
the the native americans that he
encountered i mentioned this a little
bit earlier
we're all sorts of different people and
some of them were good and some of them
were not so good and some of the groups
of native of native caribbeans were good
and some of them were not so good and
the thing we find about them when we
read columbus's
writings when we read the writings of
other people who are on the voyage is
that those indigenous peoples
were a lot like us that is they were
people
and they had some good characteristics
and they had some bad characteristics
and the way that these peoples developed
over time like when you're talking about
that interaction of columbus with the
natives there you're talking about the
first
modern colonial interactions in
in the modern era and so if there are
going to be problems if they're going to
be failures if they're going to be
mistakes made
recognize you're talking about something
that is so historic that that columbus
is credited in many ways with giving
birth to
this modern era that we're all living in
would you like to see the the modern
american italian community stand up more
for
columbus's legacy i mean that episode of
the sopranos i know the one you're
talking about it's the very famous
columbus day episode when they're trying
to tear down you know some activists are
trying to tear down a statue somewhere
in jersey um i wonder should should the
italian community be getting more up in
arms over this
i i do think that the italians have a
special role here in defending columbus
you know i don't love identity politics
and it's not like i wake up every
morning and i think gosh i'm proudest of
the fact that my skin is a little
swarthy and i eat cannoli and things
like that
but the italians have a special role
here if they're if they're not going to
defend columbus who will and the
italians ought to be
happy about their influence on america
you know i mean there are a lot of
first of all america is named after an
italian americo vespucci the map maker
uh you've got the varezano bridge you've
got uh you know christopher columbus
obviously so many places named after him
and i think this raises another question
why are towns universities state
countries old countries named after
christopher columbus why did people once
admire him and they don't admire him
anymore i suppose part of that might be
because unscrupulous journalists are
relying on ridiculous historical records
but but i suspect it has to do more with
ourselves you know we just we don't like
ourselves so much anymore as a as a
civilization and columbus because he
played such a role in in developing that
civilization and embodying it i think he
bears a lot of the the brunt of this
sort of thing you know you asked for
interesting episodes from those first
encounters he had well most of what we
see from those earliest encounters
between columbus and the natives are him
imploring people to treat them well do
not
please spaniards do not deceive the
natives do not deceive them in trade do
not be too harsh on them and and you
know that side of the man you never
really get to see
later on more difficult you know
circumstances developed of course no one
no one is denying that but what it
reminds me of chesterton's fence you
know chester gk chesterton the english
writer has this this famous idea that uh
there are two kinds of reformers right
the reformer who goes up and sees a
fence in the middle of nowhere just a
white fence doesn't seem to serve any
purpose and he says tear down that fence
i have no reason i have no idea why that
fence was erected in the first place and
then there's another type of reformer
who says hold on a second
if you do not know the purpose of that
fence if you don't know why that was
erected in the first place then don't
touch it
go figure out why it was erected in the
first place and then tear it down and i
think that's that's what what we should
begin with here is a little bit of
humility to say
why was this man admired for so very
long well maybe maybe shockingly it's us
here in 2021 who are missing something
and it's not just the deluded old awful
people who came before us that we've got
to tear down
well that kind of feels like the right
ending
i think you did it you brought the old
into the new you brought the old world
to the new world
you know we bridged the sea
we
we have done it we've reached the sea i
hope we can defend
the great christopher columbus i hope
people don't tear down his statues too
much into the near future because the
thing is when you when you tear down
your entire country when you tear down
your entire civilization
one uh some of those statues might
clobber you and clobber the things that
you love but but you're going to end up
living amid ruins and and
all cultures all civilizations we're
going to have to admire certain people
we're going to have to admire certain
values and i i want to live in a
civilization that admires the great men
who came before us who gave us our
culture that admires the intrepid
determined
faithful intelligent
ambitious sort of
episodes that that i think are really
well typified and really well
exemplified by christopher columbus or
we're going to admire a lot of the bad
guys who are running around running
rough shot over our culture make your
choice everybody's got to serve somebody
in many ways that's exactly what the
whole damn thing is about right now and
knowles you are the living embodiment of
christopher columbus because you left
los angeles for the unchartered the
unknown country country of tennessee
it's a country this is true and i've and
i just like christopher columbus i've
had wonderful encounters with the
natives here in tennessee as well
mills thanks for doing this have a happy
columbus day and i'll see you in
tennessee soon and then we'll see if we
can if they'll let you back in la i have
no
idea ciao
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell